In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for September 11, on which we commemorate, St. Daniel of
Wales, St. Daniel was a shining light of the British Church in the 6th century.
Like his holy contemporaries, David and Diffrig, he was both Bishop and Abbott, following
the order customary in the Celtic churches.
He established his cathedral at Bangor in Gwyneth, North Wales and founded two monasteries,
Bangor Vauer, near Angelsay, and Bangor Eastcoid on the River D near Chester, which was the largest
and most renowned British monastery of its day.
It consisted of seven separate houses, each inhabited by 300 or more monks, who lived
in prayer and osquices by the labor of their hands, making intercession for the Britons
hard-pressed by the still pagan Anglo-Saxons.
St. Daniel died in peace in about the year 584, through the prayers of our Holy Fathers
or Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.